hey it's Justine and today we have the
brand new DJI mini 3. now the last drone
that came out in the mini category was
the Mini 3 Pro and now we have
the mini three now the main difference
is the price you're gonna have a huge
price difference so this is coming in at
a more affordable price for people who
may be beginners maybe this is your
first drone this is going to be a great
one to start with you're not going to be
able to shoot 4K 60 like you could on
the pro but you will be able to shoot 4K
30. the transmission won't be as far and
it is lacking the obstacle avoidance on
the front and on the top but you will
have the obstacle avoidance on the
bottom so I'm excited to try this out
I'm gonna be going to Hawaii for an
event so of course we're going to be
taking this with me I love this drone so
much because of this size it's so small
it's portable it's Compact and you can
get some incredible footage
I also love that this comes with a
controller so you really don't even need
a phone everything that you need is here
in the Box this does use the same
batteries as the mini pro it's got a
nice carrying case
let's open it up
controller accessories batteries and the
Drone
it's so shockingly small I just cannot
get over it
oh my God I never hit record on the top
camera
no we have had a tragedy I can't
recreate it because it's already open so
here's the tiny little drone it does
have these small little sensors at the
bottom so that's your obstacle avoidance
and it is lacking the front obstacle
avoidance sensors but this thing is just
so
small that I just can't get over it
and here's the controller so you'll see
the back we've got our C2 C1 buttons
this is actually a pretty slim
controller and I even kind of like
having the display be below the
joysticks even though it is a large
display and it is kind of a large
controller it's pretty slim so it does
fit very nicely into all of my travel
bags I love it we've also got some
batteries this does have the charging
dock with it which is very nice
this was so light I didn't even realize
that there was a battery in it it's like
paper
and this is 249 grams
which means it is light enough you don't
have to register it with the FAA see
what else we've got
add some cables and these propellers do
need to be screwed in and out so you've
got your little screwdriver here we've
got extra propellers
there they are these always remind me of
like a little packet of candy but
they're propellers
[Music]
so here's everything that comes in the
box we have our battery charger so this
allows you to charge three batteries it
does come with two extras and there is
one already inside the Drone we've got
extra propellers we've got our USB
cables to charge we've got a little
screwdriver here that lets you adjust
the props if you need to make a change
swap those out sometimes we hit things
and of course we have our controller and
I love this controller so much it's so
beautiful and it's so nice having an
integrated screen inside of your
controller like you don't need to have a
phone don't need to worry about anything
it's just all right here so this is the
whole kit I'll put a link in the
description if you want to check this
out get more information or to purchase
but for now I'm gonna go pack this up
and take it to Hawaii are you riding my
little friend
pack your bags we're going on a road
trip it's a plane trip actually we're
going we're going on a plane trip
[Music]
foreign
good morning we are here in Maui and I'm
going to be taking this little baby
mavic 3 on its first flight it's so
beautiful here I tried to get out a
little bit earlier before the sun came
out so that we'd have a little better
lighting so let's get this thing booted
up and into the air
foreign
[Music]
s is this controller because you don't
need to use your phone like right now
I'm using my phone to film this video
it's just a beautiful screen the display
looks incredible and this drone so far
feels super responsive I'm up really
high right now I have reached our
maximum altitude
I can't actually oh I can see it there
you are oh yeah the sun just popped
looking lit
[Music]
one thing that is really cool that you
can do with this is you have the ability
to flip it into verticals if you don't
want to film horizontal you want to film
something for tick tock or for Instagram
reels you just hit this button right
here and look at us we are now recording
in vertical
it's really hard to film and talk and
fly a drone at the same time not gonna
lie another thing that I love about DJI
software and a bunch of their drones is
they have this thing called quick shots
if you've watched any of my drone videos
before you've definitely seen me do
these so I'm going to test out a couple
of these there are a lot of people on
the beach so I may not be able to test
out all of them but I definitely think
that's my favorite is the droney we're
gonna highlight ourselves
and then I'm gonna hit start
and here we go
that man was very close to my drone and
just ran right under it so we love to
see it
[Music]
okay the next one we're gonna try is
Rockets
[Music]
I really like this one this is the
circle and I think I can probably pull
this off you can't adjust the diameter
of the circle so you are able to confine
yourself to a smaller space and which
I'm gonna have to do because the tide is
up and people are out
so I'll ever far out you put it is how
far it will continue around so it's
basically just circling around you
which is what's happening right now this
does also have photo mode so you can
take some photos which is crazy because
until I went on my last trip to
Indonesia I actually not that I forgot
that my drone could take photos I just
never did it was something that I didn't
focus a lot on so I've been taking more
photos with my drones recently and this
has a Pano mode which is really cool
because it takes a bunch of photos in
different angles then it automatically
stitches them together
it's doing it it's doing it dude the
battery life is incredible like I've
been flying for a very long time and it
wasn't even fully charged and I'm at 21
right now that's the one thing about
this smaller drone is the fact of the
battery life still so good
[Music]
we're in sport mode now baby whoa
oh yeah
that's fast way faster
[Music]
sport mode makes a huge difference it's
so fast this also has a cinematic mode
which will allow you to get some super
smooth very crisp cinematic shots but
man there's nothing more satisfying than
flying in sport mode another cool thing
you can do is this does have a digital
Zoom so right now I'm at 1X I can zoom
into 2X
looks pretty good actually the thing I
will advise you is if you ever do fly a
drone zoomed in you will kind of lose
perspective of where you are because the
zoom definitely is deceiving so be very
careful if you are flying with the zoom
on
[Music]
all right I'm gonna bring it back down
this is so much fun to get a chance to
check out and I'm such a huge fan of the
mavic mini line because they are so
small so portable so compact but also
very quiet so they're not going to be
disturbing a lot of people if you are
out flying it and it is one of my
favorite drones I think the real
question is are you going to get the pro
version or this new mavic 3 I do like
the pro version because it does have a
few of the extra obstacle avoidance
sensors so if that is something that you
are concerned with then I definitely
recommend getting the pro but now that
they do have the smaller less expensive
version it's pretty much the same it
flies the same the footage already looks
incredible so I'm super excited about
this so if you guys want to get more
information about the new mavic Mini 3 I
will put a link in the description feel
free to check it out if you guys have
any questions feel free to leave them in
the comments below and I'll see you guys
in the next video where are you you're
so it's so far away
[Music]
I love chatting with people but it is uh
very hard to chat and fly and make sure
your drone is staying in the air so if
you ever want to chat with a drone pilot
it's probably best that he's really busy
you don't
[Music]